big developing story tonight surrounding
air force
commander lieutenant colonel matthew
lomeyer who was removed from his post on
friday after he made explosive
revelations about the increasing
presence of marxist and critical race
theory ideologies
inside the u.s military comments he made
on a recent podcast and in reference to
his self-published book
lowmeyer says he did consult with his
superiors about how
this critical race theory push was
causing unnecessary divisions
inside our armed forces and says he also
obtained counsel from a public affairs
officer
and base legal so why fired why why did
this happen
here to explain author of the new book
irresistible
revolution lieutenant colonel matthew
lomaire who is now by the way speaking
in his personal capacity
not his views they don't necessarily
reflect the official policy of the
department of defense
okay tell us exactly what happened
sean i appreciate you having me on the
show and in fact that statement that you
just read that came from air force
public affairs
i included in the front of my book three
times once on the copyright page once in
the front matter
and again in the introduction to the
book
what happened is i began noticing some
time ago
and not just in the past few months but
over the past several years
an increasing relevance of what i saw
was
marxist ideology parading around by
other names
the defense secretary in february i
think it was february 5th of this year
called for an extremism down day and
issued a guidance memorandum to all
service members and in the guidance
memorandum he
basically gave an injunction to every
service member to combat extremist
ideologies
within the force where they saw them and
to take it upon ourselves to protect one
another and to speak up and educate one
another about
extremist ideologies when we discover
them causing divisions within the force
and that's me paraphrasing the guidance
memorandum so i
include that in the introduction to the
book as well okay so you had recognized
the narratives
as being marxist in nature your words
not mine and also you said it teaches
intensive teaching that i heard at the
base at a time the constitution ratified
the us
codified white supremacy is the law of
the land
uh are they not aware that uh we fought
a civil war
that the 64-65 civil rights act voting
rights act that joe biden's friend by
the way
filibustered side note while not perfect
we have made incredible strides have
incredible more to go
towards a more perfect union is that not
recognized at all
i think it is recognized and i think you
know one of the things the defense
department does very well is
make it very clear that we've got zero
tolerance for discrimination of any kind
based on race uh sex politics religion
ex and so that's the standard right and
so
to that end i've made that very clear to
my own people
that in the light of a hyper-politicized
environment
that i've seen since taking command and
i'm no longer in command
i will not tolerate any discrimination
of any kind based on politics
for example and so let me give you one
example of what i saw
in the past 10 months when i was in
command of a unit
there were videos being sent out to
every base service member that we were
asked to watch in preparation for
our extremism down days and discussions
on race
in which we were taught that the country
was evil that it was founded
in 1619 and not 1776 and that whites are
inherently evil
and so i speak up against those things
in my book i think in the military
that you talk about a brotherhood and a
bond that really is kind of
unimaginable in real life because you
all have each other's back on the
battlefield
thank you for updating us appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else